اذا التقييم والاستراتيجي لي تل ابيب يطرح
النووي الايرانيه على انه اكبر تهديد لعام
2023 هذا اسرائيليا وبالطبع امريكيا التي
ستكون حازمه في مواجهه اي تعاون اي يتعارض
مع اهدافها بعدم الانتشار النووي الخطر
الملح يزدادوا الحاحا مع التوتر
الاسرائيلي روسي خاصه في اعقابه سحب
الولايات المتحده مخزونها الاستراتيجيه
الكبير لدى اسرائيل سينما القبائل
المدفعيه ونقلها الى اوكرانيا
اسرائيل باتت تعمل ضد موسكو والاخيره
لديها ما تفعله في المقابل صحيفه كومسيون
مول
لماذا بالمقابل لا تعزز روسيا جيوش جيران
اسرائيل ليس تساؤلا صحفيا بحثا جيران
اسرائيل في هذه الحاله ايران المدعومه
روسيا دبلوماسيه امام مج- مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه او في مجلس
الامن ستمددها موسكو بحسب معهد واشنطن
للسياسات بالتكنولوجيا والمعرفه النوويه
وروسيا هي من بنى مفعل بوشهر وتمد ايران
بالوقود اللازم لتشغيله وتقوم ببناءه
فاعلين اضافيين لها الطلب الايراني قدم
بالفعل مواد نوويه اضافيه وتصنيع وقود
نوويه بحسب ما نقلات السي ان ان عن
مسؤولينا امريكيين
وذلك في اطار تهيئه ايران للخطباء او
البديله عن الاتفاق النووي لكن التقييم
الاخضر قدمه مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافاييل جروسي حضر من ان طهران بات
تملكو موده كافيه لصنع عده اسلحه نوويه